the Joe Rogan experience I read The God
Delusion in in preparation for this do
you pull that microphone right up to
your face just get it about a fist away
from your face you have to move okay the
microphone move for you I'm a huge fan
II work and I always wanted to ask you
it you you go so hard against religion
and you have for so long has there ever
been a time where you've gotten fatigued
from this were you like I just leave
this to somebody else well obviously not
because I just it's not so hard as you
think I mean you remember it as hard but
actually if you read it again I think
you'd find it was not as hard as you
remember I didn't mean hard in in a
negative sense I mean you push your okay
you're so enthusiastic about you're
enthusiastic yes I'm also humorous I
mean I like to think it's a funny book
but a lot of people do think it's hard
in the other sense and and sometimes
when they read it again they realize
actually no it's more humorous it's not
so not so edgy not so hard-hitting as as
they think as they originally thought it
was well I think that's probably because
you've had some interviews in the past
we have talked to some fiercely
religious people and you've had some
cantankerous interactions with them I
think maybe so they they associate you
with having this almost aggressively
atheistic stance yes well perhaps you're
thinking better Riley well I mean he's
aggressive all right yeah they're in the
other way I did once had to tell him
will you please stop interrupting me and
let me talk and and so that might give
this slight impression that I'm
addressing no what was that BBC
documentary that you you had done well
you you had done several the one where
you had gone and interviewed a bunch of
different religious people yes that was
not BBC that was Channel four which is
the commercial station and yes I
interviewed Ted Haggard yes and a guy
who ran a thing called hell not hell
holes hell hell hell houses where they
write tried to terrify children
I mean freaked them out with horrible
little plays little play lists
yeah the devil coming on with horns and
glowing eyes and
I actually participated in a reenactment
of that play in Los Angeles back in the
day a comedy reenactment Bill Maher was
in it a bunch of other comedians were in
it and we read word for word the the
script and we acted it out in front of a
live audience so people would come
through the Hell House yeah this haunted
house but instead it was people knew it
was all comedians reading and they like
is this really the words that they said
yeah it was so preposterous that it
actually without being a parody it
actually played out like a comedy when
we filmed it we filmed them doing the
play and then we filmed me interviewing
the perpetrator Michael somebody or
other yeah and I said to him what's your
target audience and he said 12 and I
said really are you are you really
serious that you liked
he said hell is at a terrible place that
anything I can do to persuade children
not to sin and they must acknowledge in
knowledge Jesus and so on is is worth it
I thought that was a deeply immoral
thing to say but I think he was sincere
yeah well I would agree with you is it's
it's very disturbing that that was a
there's a great documentary on it as
well for someone who wants to see like
the thought process behind them creating
this but one of the things I really
enjoyed about The God Delusion is that
you you kind of outlined every single
possible argument against atheism and
then how to counter to it in advance
like if you you know you you have a soft
position look at chapter 1 if you look
at this look at chapter 2 and you you
outline that in the preface before you
got into it yes well I tried to be as
persuasive as possible the new book
outgoing God is sort of aimed at a
younger audience and I like to think
that could be read at any age but being
able to a younger audience is bit
shorter and perhaps some a bit easier to
follow I'm not sure
[Applause]